and so Linda for you seeing Judy's Arc
this season what was your reaction when
you when you saw that that's the way it
was going to play out I knew from uh
when we were shooting season two Liz had
had told me what the idea was and she's
like I'm not sure but I think I'm gonna
do this and I said great because
whatever she thinks of it it just
magically becomes this really
interesting fun thing to play so I knew
I knew that there would be Not only
would it be something that I would get
to play but it also would have greater
meaning for the entire show and I think
because of Judy's journey I think you
sort of understand what Liz calls the
themes of the show which is friendship
grief love and forgiveness right it's a
loss of forgiveness and so I think that
because of what happens it really sort
of pinpoints that for us
um so I was I was you know I was as
happy as you can be about it
you know thank you and I'm sorry no it's
good and I you know I thought I thought
it worked out now I know why you love
this car right
I'm so glad it's yours now
thank you
[Music]
yeah it worked out it works out very
well oh well not for Judy but nothing
ever does though James you're you're
like one of the last people see on on
screen I'm
yeah the show ends with me which is cool
what was your question I mean look it's
we keep talking about how bittersweet is
and how much of a family we've become
and and our friendships have grown and
just through this you know professional
working relationship that it started as
and now we're sort of closing the book
on this story and it's really
um you know we get emotional I get
emotional thinking about it and um but
um but I think the audience is gonna
love what we have for them and um
everyone I know everyone poured their
hearts and souls into it so hopefully
soon according to them as it is for for
us to do to present to them I didn't
realize that you were in so much pain
ah I didn't want you to realize
how long has it been like this
when something starts as like a little
pain
I was there one day and not the next and
then
is there more days and then it just kind
of learn to live with it so Liz you you
had come up with Judy getting cancer and
it's kind of going off having it be
terminal Midway through season two or
however so I was curious watching it
obviously because you know Christina had
come forward with her health diagnosis
with MS and as far as I understand
revealing it to you guys part way
through the season or about at least the
beginning of work how much had to be
shifted as far as the plot Dynamics once
she made that Revelation to you guys the
truth is nothing changed in terms of the
story we had already shot about 50 of
the Season by the time Christina
received her diagnosis so there wasn't
really any going back because we shoot
dead to me completely out of order so we
had shot scenes from all 10 episodes by
the time uh the news came in and there
was really no way to you know rewrite or
or change anything and also we didn't
want to Christina felt very strong only
about telling the story that we wanted
to tell from the beginning and and
that's what we did and you know I I'm
really grateful that we got to stick
with the story as intended and
um you know it was uh it was like an all
hands on deck situation getting it all
made yeah I mean speaking of the all
hands on deck what were some of those
things that you guys had to do in order
to Rally around her to Aid her and as
best you could I think we we made any
accommodation that she felt or we felt
was necessary and just as we would for
anybody that was going through you know
any kind of Health Challenge for
Christina sometimes that meant that she
held on to a door as she walked in or
you know that that she and Linda were
arm in arm just to help her with her
balance but you know those things were
really pretty minimal and I I think you
know for me something that is miraculous
is when you watch the show I don't think
you'll even really notice you know this
is brilliant as ever I mean she's
absolutely brilliant as is Linda is
James and and you know we just we just
rally around each other you know we've
we've all gone through you know
difficult moments in the course of you
know four years of making a show
um and so we were already in practice of
being there for each other and being a
support to one another and and this you
know just continued that Linda do you I
mean and people are gonna say this and I
don't think there's any Merit to it but
like
I'm leaving because people are going to
be like you know online and be like we
never we don't see Judy actually pass
away we don't see you like I feel the
series is pretty definitive but I mean
what's your take on that like what would
you say to people like well we never saw
her like she could be out there living
her best life she could be the one who
beats the odds and comes back I think
that's the point of it too I think it is
it is ambiguous on purpose and rightless
yes yes and so you know I hesitate to
say what I truly think because that also
you know could could color somebody
else's Narrative of what they think
happens just because I play her but I
think that it was purposefully crafted
that way so that you know
um you kind of make your own assumptions
about what happens and and where she
goes
um whether is that that's here on Earth
or not
[Music]
Ben
yeah
I have to tell you something a James in
that last moment when we when it seems
like Christina is going to tell Ben what
happens do you I mean I saw the same
question maybe it's best left ambiguous
but what do you think Ben's reaction was
to finding out if that's what in fact
what she was gonna tell him let's
presuppose it that's what I'm gonna Echo
Linda's sentiment and I don't want to
color that sort of interpretation for
any of the viewers I mean I I have my
own personal thoughts and feelings about
what that what his reaction would be but
I feel like when you're making art you
know sometimes it's nice when you don't
have everything kind of tidied up with a
little bow on top and that there is
ambiguity and and that's there's sort of
an abstract nature to that but it also
can be
you know part of the art that you're
presenting and I don't know I know
that's the kind of like
running around the question kind of
answer but I I do believe that I do
believe it I think that it can offer up
conversation afterwards with everyone
who watched it together yeah I think you
all can share what yeah what they all
think if it's good enough for The
Sopranos it's good enough for dead to me
exactly but it's also very dead to me
because we always have some kind of like
little question unanswered so yeah what
was it like seeing Christina and Katie
have this beautiful on-screen reunion
Katie's awesome I mean Katie's
incredible I didn't realize that you
were
out and about
so Judy's told you about me huh and it
was it was great just to see Katie and
Linda play you know mother and daughter
amazing the sort of fun weird dramatic
irony of that but then once we you know
once we had Katie on the show of course
I was like well we have to put Katie and
Christina in a scene together we have to
bring you know these two and actually
allow them to play the kind of scene
that they've never gotten to play
together which is a pretty dramatic
charged you know a scene full of vitriol
and resentment and I think they're
absolutely brilliant in it I I mean I
could have watched it all day and I
actually did I did watch it
I said something very satisfying about
seeing them together super satisfying
yeah
[Music]